what is going on there reject Nation
Greg John and look who's back after
missing episode three just the worst
person we need a white Savior for a Miss
Marvel showing what you're him and I
know what I know what I'm ready
guys we're gonna watch Miss Marvel
episode 4 today and we got of course got
koi genre joining us again follow him on
Tick Tock where he does plenty of like
60 seconds to three minute breakdowns of
a bunch of Marvel is this if you like
Marvel go follow him there all right
comps in general always asking me to
plug it and I'm like shut up boy I've
actually I'm just like come here on my
little elbow I see those million Tick
Tock subscribers so I'm relevant guys
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated as soon as they also
subscribe to John I think they should
also subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
the next Miss Marvel's up also uh
full-length watch along three sync up
with the time code available for our
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page over there I cover plenty of shows
we're at the same tier we have some
shows we're exclusively reaction
highlights and watch Longs include did
and lastly thinking of them prepper boys
for helping us edit down these
highlights let's get to it
[Music]
you both need to come to Karachi
still waiting for when they do the
traditional Marvel the the swelling yeah
however I love the needle drops they do
I've been really good in the show yeah
if it's not connected to the MCU I don't
care about anything in this world what
are what are songs they created Pakistan
for the comics right these mics are the
death of us
[Music]
it was a really good through glass the
comologists get on a plane
foreign
[Music]
because your Nani is very old and she
insisted on us coming to Pakistan I
think that we need to call a temporary
truce I don't know I thought you got on
the plane by herself
whatever it is that you've been up to
lately
the National Airport
[Music]
Naki is upset why are friends in these
superhero shows always upset when they
find out that their friends is super
gonna be so excited
children yes
you are taller than I remember you are
still really foolish burn
middle of the night you should be
sleeping oh come on I'm just coming from
a party
yeah Grandma
hi Mommy
attention welcome home thank you it's
good to be here
your skin is so dry oh no spoken like a
mother
I like that it's not all in New York
that's nice yeah yeah look at us
venturing oh the pita look delicious
yeah multiverses have done great things
for opening titles
[Music]
a dog too
Pita dog
no
holy crap what a fancy ass we're gonna
give someone I had no idea you could
draw
we lost so much during partition
beautiful
looks like when she first put on the
Bengal this is Miami Aisha
your great grandmother
what I could remember of her at least
about that we've met have you heard of
gins
why did you send this to me
am I
a June of course at least that is what
my father told me
actual about this
I I don't see what the whole verse is
about it's just genetics
I feel like I'm trying to piece together
100 different things and I just I'm
breaking more than I can fix if you have
lived like I have to learn to find
beauty in the pieces
I like this old lady give her powers the
show is so well cast the family feels
like family it's so comfortable yeah I
feel like Coy's Boston family yeah
definitely Boston
basically stand-ins for you guys I mean
I'm that sloth
let's rock a raccoon guys who's right oh
sorry I didn't realize you were in here
with someone
napping pillow come on get up we have
the whole afternoon plan lunch at the
board Club is in one hour it's really
examining that is this a pillow
we're here to visit the point is to
visit
so let's go come on how do you monetize
this trip oh there are plenty of ways
policy this outfit plays a lot better in
Jersey
not a typical Pakistani name it's not I
mean
well that's quite my neighbor though she
always was a bitter forever
this is where some of karachi's oldest
residents live
I like Florida
the old town is where many of the
refugees first settled when they came
from India
so not like Florida
[Music]
although it'd be funny if there was a
Karachi man the same way there's a
Florida man always fighting alligators
foreign
[Music]
condescending cousin you know it's like
the first ever Gateway where Nani
entered the country
uh well we're going meet us after stay
safe I guess
[Music]
wow excellent they care about their
cousin neglectful it's yours if you tell
me the direction to the train station
training station
um
yeah I left oh no
one more left and then right little
little bit right
a little bit right
surprisingly very accurate directions
it was a little bit right it was just a
little bit that makes the difference
[Music]
okay now she's a Superhero now you don't
draw attention to yourself matches her
blue and yellow shirt Choice where'd
Kamala go
who knows oh
[Music]
bringing in red dagger found you
not sure what's worse those glasses you
try on with that mask are you
I sensed the newer
yeah buddy oh he was prepared
[Music]
Paco to all my family can have
superpowers well
[Music]
oh my God you're destroying this
historic train station people probably
be nicer if you're a Canadian
[Music]
superhero Landing with purpose you're
not a clandestine
but you have the bangle
how did you get in from Aisha
how do you know about Aisha
[Music]
getting always wanted to say that but
really we should go there's so many you
need to meet she meets all the greatest
guys doesn't she just well sorry
trustworthy dude best boys
Chinese restaurant but this isn't China
whoa whoa how does that work
you ordered ahead that's some fourth one
yeah
foreign
this looks way nicer than the restaurant
[Music]
yeah it's like the Ancient Temple behind
the Papa John's and Uncharted very
important have that Papa John's
historic apparels they're gonna pay Mark
Wahlberg
but for a descendant of Aisha
[Music]
I'm sure we can make an exception how
did you know my name is Waleed
your great-grandmother's story is of
Legend when you're ready
we have much to discuss I could look
like him one day oh easily yeah like two
weeks so red that's the color it's
supposed to be
did you American find a way to whitewash
the Chinese food too
yes sir the clandestines are not like
the Gin you've heard about stories on
religious texts so what are they
and what am I I'll show you
what are you guys talking about very
videos coming soon
[Music]
it looks familiar The Veil The
clandestines
even your powers are made of it if the
clandestines use the bangle to tear down
the Bell they'll unleash their world
onto us until there's nothing left of it
oh God again
all right guys I was trying to conquer
the world
we're mining more problems it says what
you seek is seeking you
Captain Marvel
[Music]
oh wow
nice
how is he he'll be okay oh
let's go
[Music]
this group man having fun let him go
he's not coming with us
what
she made his choice but mama oh he has
to live with it he just got you out
let me oh it's actually kind of sad when
he says it he looks like such a child
there
no oh poor guy I'm still trying to
figure out who I am do you think you're
ever gonna figure it out
[Music]
watch The Rush
[Music]
[Music]
your name is minced meat no it's it's
chemo
short for Karim we all go by nicknames
here right yeah what's yours uh sloth
baby
sloth baby
call her sloth baby it's not baby cool
name thank you thank you at least
someone appreciates it
all right you ready for the best meal of
your life very different vibe when his
hair is down
the Thorp mayor didn't recognize him
until now
[Music]
she just asked me if it was spicy she's
gonna [ __ ] her pants
she's gonna die
[Music]
excited
[Music]
oh my God the chemistry she forms to all
these guys except for Brian Bruno and
Brian
Brandon Ryan Brandon Brandon Bob Barry
I know what did he call him we call him
Brian Brian
I got the joke right you just didn't get
it I just didn't get a job jokes are the
best we have to explain everyone knows
you like them as a child so I just kept
them around just in case you came back
I may have eaten most of them along the
way it sounds like an excuse to be a
hoarder this is an intervention and even
after Baba left you you continued to
cling to these fantastic theories
just thought I'd share them with you I
didn't need your stories mummy I needed
my mother
damn good actress man
how vibrant everything is the walls the
sheets everything are awesome you know I
was really depressing scene and you were
just focusing ones
I feel so happy
see now she's happy again like the
colors
sit sit have a toffee
oh it's 20 years old
we believe your genetics could be the
answer to why it is that you can shape
the new head
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
[Laughter]
you should know
but his history in every thread of this
fabric
so you always remember where you came
from
this is starting to look familiar
am I a red dagger now it suits you
ah crap they got there fast
oh [ __ ] this guy can fight
wow yeah
I like this guy
oh no
hey go get in quick oh yes yes live for
these action scenes
[Music]
no it's like T2 in Jurassic Park
references in here
[Music]
I can't go any faster
don't work
dang
oh Jesus no kill them
there'll be cowards Marvel
[Music]
ramp awesome
and then it just explodes
the whole block explodes Easter eggs
everyone's looking for my voice
is that practical holy crap
[Music]
oh
goody
this house is empty
come on
they just follow like animals on them
that's all it takes okay that's the move
okay
one guy then
driving on the opposite side of the road
[Music]
yeah buddy
this poor guy yeah get out of there guy
I want this oh all that money
murder
we have to go
aren't you better off in the truck
probably okay he should drive
[Music]
oh please jump to another Roof oh
come on
parkour yes
oh no
[Music]
oh
there you go
oh yeah
critical moments
no
[Music]
no no no
oh yeah
no no it's too late he's gone we have to
go I like to I thought that explosion
would be worse yeah it's just a little
sprayed a lot of liquid around
[Laughter]
[Music]
cool beans
[Music]
nice oh not bad man
[Music]
oh
you know she's turning into a hell of a
fighter
the clothes
oh so this guy just straight up killed
just murdering American people left and
right
[Music]
oh oh
oh
dang
cheat in the past yeah she is she's at
the partition
s
[Music]
so this isn't just some like Vision
she's having she's like there it's like
it feels like people are like avoiding
her
foreign
actually seemed to be touching her yeah
yeah like she's in a physical space
wow those look like real ass extras they
got
yeah this looks like like one of those
shots from an old movie
what a note to end on Wow crazy stuff a
deal in below
do you think there's a post credit scene
maybe I doubt it would be of her maybe
of some maybe the people back home maybe
even Ikea or Brian or Brian or the
pillow what is the sloth doing now it
moves his head
slowly that's why he was getting checked
out so thoroughly that's right
[Laughter]
above the lottery man she's awesome
she's real good at the Charming
we're good at this time and stuff she's
just so natural it's crazy yeah this was
like the most
it's interesting even though they're not
in like the East Coast this we also felt
the most Marvel episode to me out of the
four because the action meets you know
family dialogue stuff because we entered
the sanctum sanctorum yeah because
Doctor Strange was in here no it's just
like uh they just deep dived so much
into like lower power history and then a
bunch of action
cool I like how they changed the credits
here
a [ __ ] Georgia will return
she'll be back in Georgia
dang I missed the director credit on
this one
huh there's Sam Raimi
I knew it he's the guy to tell this
story director of quick and the dead
that's why there was so much spooky well
I should see quick in the dead someday
no you should little baby Leo yeah a
little DiCaprio and I Gotta See dark man
got some Sam ready to catch up on
this is what the patrons want oh IMDb
all right guys we're gonna review Elvis
actually really excited for that I'm
excited for Elvis you haven't seen it no
no oh cool what's the matter with you
was it good I haven't seen it yet yeah
I've heard the last 40 minutes or like
how Coy's brain works all the time yes
and then koi Kane and then 45 minutes in
Greg has to go no no no so the first 40
minutes are shutting and then down what
are you saying become a real movie now
what is the Nexus two hours are koi on
LSD which is a calmer but more colorful
experience and I'll notice the beautiful
walls and uh tapestries that we will
you'll get a lot you'll walk around
inside very pretty set design here gosh
damn it John
shut up so we can talk more red dagger
yeah that was uh that was a good episode
I I weirdly prefer this show I don't
know if it's weird I I like I like this
show more weirdly when I forget that
it's a Marvel show like like when it's
just focused on her family and her
relationships and the culture because
I'm a pretentious snob that's the only
reason why I like that stuff it has
nothing to do with you know me actually
I just want more bang bang action
I'm just saying [ __ ] to sound like a
more sophisticated
um but no I I actually uh I'm I'm really
into that stuff and I and there's
something that doesn't feel
sometimes I think the explanation I feel
like you probably generate a lot from
those moments when they're like
clandestines fails and all that jazz
yeah they're just like yes information
absorption how is this connecting to the
thing that I think it might be a
mythology from the comic books okay yeah
see after you like eat that up and for
me I those scenes are are just not as
compelling are you not as invested in
the mythology in General on the show or
just the expositions or like do you
prefer like are does it feel Exposition
dumpy to you since you're not as
invested uh I guess the show's not
really investing me into the exposition
okay of some of those scenes is this
usually something in a Marvel property
that is less I usually I can get I
usually like the balance of both I
usually enjoy I can get on board for
when I was someone who hears Exposition
and goes Exposition screw that you know
there are other people like that uh it
all just depends to me on it I guess
because I'm So Into the other stuff yeah
that um it's it's weird like I think I
like the action and I don't mind the
information I don't want it to sound
like I don't like I'm just not I just
don't find that's I guess like this show
has two things about it right it has you
know Kamala Khan discovering the roots
of her family the relationships there
and you know her place in this world as
just like a Pakistani American girl you
know right like that's what that's like
the one show and then the other show is
the Bengal and and clandestines and all
these things and I I actually like the
former
um the most and the show definitely
leads with that like you prefer the
midst of the Marvel yeah yeah and I feel
like the Marvel part will probably be
most intriguing by the time you see her
like crossing over but don't get me
wrong I think the action is actually
weirdly from the trailers and stuff I
thought the action might be the thing
that is not that great about this series
but between last episode and this
episode The Action can genuinely
surprise me a lot of the time like I
have really more practical than I
expected definitely I think the the
chasing
um was pretty cool it was a lot more
stunt work than I was expecting and they
they just utilized a lot more that was
like a [ __ ] that's like 15 minutes
the episode went by because that like
that mid piece was so much longer than I
realized because suddenly we were like
oh we're in the third Act of the show
yeah I also felt like it was uh uh
really well choreographed for how much
was going on like I there was more color
than normal because it wasn't just in
New York and I could still tell what was
going on at all times like it was really
well framed and the action never got
jumpy like I was with them yeah I
completely agree and uh I mean don't
come around I I like parts of the when
the I guess when the X when the battery
was so much would justify my freaking
opinion about right why do you not like
something Greg hates motion especially
it's when it feels I like the mystery
part of the uncovering what's going on
the mystery that that mysterious hook
always gets me like like at the end with
the you know being put in the partition
and that part is like oh that's really
fascinating we haven't quite seen it
done that way because we've seen a lot
of things especially or just like they
go into the past but it's just like a
vision that I'm able to walk through but
it looks like she really somehow she's
on that train transplanted there which
is so bizarre
um but I I like the episode overall I'm
not but I mean I know you love ranking
stuff I probably say is like my
third favorite uh I don't know I don't
really care I liked it all right I don't
care break it yeah it's good it's a good
episode it's fine I think my one thing
that I really respect about it
for sure is that um I'll let you guys
just talk away you know another thing I
really respect about it for sure is you
know like we were talking between
recording here especially is that you
got a very specific kind of vibe when
they're in New Jersey and oh my God
forgive me everyone what is this place
called kamachi Karachi karachi's so
sorry so sorry to all you guys who are
offended by that but uh Karachi
not not for our actual uh Indian viewers
it's like noon or whatever there yeah so
um and we got a good amount of you guys
and um yeah so I I like the way how they
really capture the vibe there like this
show seems to be uh the direction seems
to do such a good job at capturing the
vibe of whatever City it's inhabiting
the environment is what I'm getting at
and I really like how it it felt like a
different show but the same show and I
really think that's cool how much they
you get a chance to to live in the
environments and really see the cool
culture a lot more through that way in a
way that doesn't seem like they go
expositional about it they just let you
like live there and I think that's great
and I like how the tone does affect the
series so I I quite quite enjoy John
what you think about red dagger
does good good intro set you up
it was the last thing I expected that
was like oh sorry I was like you've dig
deep into my reserves I thought I was
thinking about a pattern opinion and
then of course that stuff
red dagger it was cool to me red dagger
I got confused at first I was like wait
a minute okay is one of the clandestine
attacking her okay wait no okay this is
a different guy and uh and yeah I I
thought he was quite Charming we don't
really get to spend much character time
with him but uh he's got long hair like
you I know I like him automatically
I mean yeah I liked him I liked their
friend like you know the little group of
friends that they wound up you know
eating with after all the chaos was done
I liked the introduction of his fight
style and I liked um I I cannot remember
the name of the guy who's like the
mentor who he's well lead there you go
was it well yeah yeah something like
that I think so close yeah and I like
the the interplay of the two of them and
I like seeing them in action I mean I'm
looking forward to learning more about
that character as a character character
and I mean this one of all of them maybe
had the most juggling to do in terms of
like you know I could watch that scene
of them like bonding around the fire for
a little bit longer or something like
that but yeah for him as a character
other than just like cool you know show
me more
um but yeah I like the expander is that
a koi you could Enlighten us on this is
that a koi
is red dagger a singular character that
they have now turned into a Consortium
or like an organization or or is it
always an organization so I don't it's
funny I was thinking that during the
episode I don't remember being an
organization I remember the character
because I and it's in Jersey City when
if memory serves when you meet him he's
in her City uh and I don't know that we
meet others but it's honestly the
earlier Arc of the comics that puts it
like seven or eight years ago
um but I really really love that they
were able to capture his physicality in
the exact way I pictured it like some of
the wall running and some of the use of
the elongated scarf and all of those
things feel just like the comic book uh
it's also I showed Greg the frame from
one of my favorite issues I think it's
issue 8 or 28 I can't remember the
number before the game but uh it's one
of the earlier I don't even remember him
doing that uh but I showed you but like
they captured like the suit so well and
like the the chemistry between the two
of them and the fact that like his
costume translates directly from page to
screen is really rad because it feels
like physically how I imagined him so I
can kind of put myself back in reading
the comic book to see which story
elements they're going to take because I
don't remember him in this environment
so I'm really curious how that
translates to the Jersey City stuff that
I do remember
his name is Walid it is
coming way late thanks for telling us
goes right five minutes later oh what's
that position called on podcasts
and this on the engineer here to to to
clarify the guy in the chair
the red dagger in the comics is just one
guy I thought so yeah and uh cream is a
Jersey City if memory serves and they
meet uh one of those like uh superhero
meat cute so they find a little first
then they realize they're on the same
side the the reveal like this it's
adorable there they go adorable so uh
who do you think she's gonna end up
going within the show because she seemed
quite into
um
umron Kareem in this show I mean I feel
like it's going to depend on what comrad
decides for his loyalty because we've
seen obviously he's conflicted uh with
you know his clandestine choices but uh
he clearly also wants to make sure his
mom's happy so is he a Mama's Boys
you're gonna he's gonna go to the good
side that's pretty obvious his mom's
really bad she's pretty bad oh no wait
he did see him so
um I could see the double blind where
they make him the villain like where she
where he has to prove himself to the
clandestine I mean it is conflicting for
him I hope they really play into the
conflict for him yeah because in the
last episode that was something it was
like Mom's pet stopping her and then
here I was like oh he does he does have
some sort of You Raised Me perhaps she's
rejecting me now now I feel bad and I'm
gonna take this out on all women I did
in the future well I do think there is
the chance to make him more villainous
uh the in this manner uh and I and I
think they'll go with the red dagger
route
um but we'll see as far as love entrance
yeah fair enough fair enough so uh
what's everything that we learned in
this episode koi about um the
clandestines well it's interesting fail
word was dropped the veil word Greg was
very confused by what is a veil that's
perfectly and sometimes it's not to be
capitalized so I was like what is the
veil
serious
you see in weddings Greg there's a thing
you wear to keep your face hidden uh and
then sometimes the Gin use it to keep
their culture hidden no I I love that
we're getting more and more mythology in
phase four and we've had uh you know in
the field of reads in Moon Knight is
very intriguing to see how you know that
is an element of uh other world and now
we've got this other you know through
the portal Looking Glass situation where
we can apparently it's kind of like the
the smelly fart Theory like you know
some some people can smell uh certain
things and other creatures can't so like
there might be creatures that live
amongst us that we just don't have the
the ability to witness and I like the
idea of using that for the supernatural
uh is this us how are we doing I'm
trying to make sure I make sure our
reactions of prepping footage in between
here asked me a question I was given a
decent an answer with smelling farts and
you're over here it's not my job to
listen to you John interact with this
guy yeah
that's all I'm asking but do you not
think it's an interesting thing that
perhaps aliens walk amongst us we just
don't have the means to witness them
yeah it's it it reminds that is an
aspect and I know Doctor Who came up a
lot during Loki but that was something
that reminded me of Doctor Who I was
like oh they're just like out of phase
with our reality right it's like layered
on top of it but the yeah the molecules
are just we just can't read them
differently displaced yeah yeah yeah and
even the the ultimate plan of like we
want to tear the Veil Down and just you
know neuroform Earth is
the exactly you know it I'm trying to
come up with another nor pun right
I really like the Greg's got the dynamic
with that I'm sorry guys
I really like the dynamic a lot with the
mom and the grandma and then watching
how she's sort of like because there was
so much of resistance towards like
superheroes because that that's
something that I'm trying to pick up on
the mom as if does she believe in any of
this stuff right now like because from
the flashback with Aisha it seemed like
she believed in in some of the stuff
that she was calling her the saying that
her the grandma was like the crazy
theories about things you know I just I
was gonna give you a little head Pat
there through the veil I'm really proud
of you do you get what I'm getting at
because I'm saying we live in a world of
crazy superheroes and [ __ ] so that she
should be she should believe in um some
of this like mystical stuff now right I
really also enjoyed the yes as well as
the US wanting to know how much she's
aware and like what that Aisha family
history is I also really liked the
family Dynamic of three generations of
who sees the train what that connection
is to the other world all the the chaos
of Greg opening times
I gotta do some [ __ ] through the door
Realms okay
let's get on track here all right it's
too much well some of us went through
the mail some have stayed all right
frankly look I'm asking this about the
mom okay I'm gonna ask us about the mom
one more time because I feel like my
question was kind of rambling as I was
multitasking perhaps
um it's just like the mom grabbed my
crap
grandma or a mom who is the daughter
she the way she was talking with her mom
about saying like wild theories and
stuff it seemed like she's rejecting
this but we saw in the flashback when
the mom the mom was with Aisha in the
flashback in episode three right I think
she's blocked it out personally my
theory is the mom is like this never
happened I don't believe in it I don't
believe in magic this is not something
our family does right right because
remember the the bangle when it first
appeared she was like nope that's
garbage like she very willingly
separated herself from it so I feel like
she has like you know but she's got to
believe in some type of level of magic
now in the weird world that we live in
of blips and all that oh absolutely but
I imagine she doesn't think it's family
I don't think she accepts that it's
happening like this generational yeah
when she talks about the partition she
likes like nope like she just is is kind
of uh compartmentalizing everything
right right
um yeah that's true but either way I
think the mama is great I like the
grandma performer freaking amazing oh
the acting in this is so good and like
every we met while lead and then within
two minutes I was like no like I was so
invested and I was worried for Forum uh
also like new dude like you know we met
Cameron and
automatically Charming
having a love triangle work cross world
is interesting like the fact that we're
wondering how that's going to go the
fact that we're still worried about him
and still invested well Kareem's
definitely gonna go to New Jersey I hope
so it's kind of weird kind of weird it's
gonna be great I think maybe maybe it'll
just be a show or Kamala Khan just
travels back and forth just hitting on
dude that would be cool I mean her mom
just lets her go back and forth I think
that would actually be cool however I
think it's I like the way they use the
pilgrimage Motif idea as a part of this
like I expected them to go back you know
and and to visit the roots but but
there's I don't know like I think a nice
parallel between like the actual
pilgrimage one might take and the coming
of age that this represents for Kamala
um and two I mean I I it makes me I love
where they ended off and that's part of
what I've been hoping for is like a real
jump back into the real past do a period
piece moment dude something with yeah a
lot of extras a lot of real production
about you do some real history and I
think think if they settle there like I
feel like the next episode has to take
place in the train station during the
partition at least for part of it and I
feel like that is an element that could
Elevate the magical newer World building
because I think that's what's missing
from that is just because this episode's
moving really fast and it's juggling on
things that is the part that feels the
most perfunctory about this episode
because it's another magic land another
magic group of people in the Marvel
Universe full of magic lands and groups
of people and I feel like if you really
so like really fuse that into the
history and keep going down that rabbit
hole of this comes from a cultural
element even if it shares similarity to
Magic across the ocean I feel like
that's what could make that feel truly
vital because right now it's like it's
cool and they got their cool sanctum
where they train and stuff but it
doesn't really feel as connected as you
do when you're transported to that train
station to me yeah it doesn't feel as
lived in I think that's what I meant
earlier here to bring it back to my
justification I don't know why I was
having issues with some of the way the
ex was because I feel like it's just
more information being thrown at me and
not seeing enough of really imbuing and
shown in that set you want to see it
shown and I think that's what episode
five is going to do show it instead of
saying let's see about that well and can
I ask then because a lot of comic book
fans and people in the comments have
have grappled with the change in power
or how the power exists and where it
comes from and why and I feel like the
strongest element through my eyes has
been when they really go through it's
something to do with your lineage and
your culture I like that change how do
you feel about that so the Inhumans are
very much part of their culture it's a
rich history and all those things that
make her tied to that and I also think
that her specific power set is tied to
puberty and body dysmorphia and going
through change and all those things so
when she stretches everything and and
feels and bigened but like ugly and
wrong like their their elements ever
been like what is this this and then she
Embraces that that doesn't really get to
be an option with these Powers but they
do get to now play with the lineage
because the nor so I'm really curious
how that all ties together because now
you can play with how it's ancestral how
it is tied to your history and like all
those things I don't know if they're
going to bring I don't now that we're
this deep I don't think in humans are
tears and mystery that's coming to play
but I do think we might meet some family
or someone in this past that might make
it feel more fleshed out and more like
it's a it's a lineage thing yeah well I
feel like with this show that it's it's
really more focused on the emotional
stuff and more of the like I think that
they're exploring in a way of like some
generational trauma well the comic's so
family based uh I I've often said that
she to me is this generation Silver age
Spider-Man and the Silver age Spider-Man
was always so invested in his friends
whether it was like Harry and Mary Jane
and Gwen like at school or uh in college
in that case or if it was like the Uncle
Ben Aunt May relationship where like he
was hiding stuff but also protecting his
little corner of New York and all those
elements feel like Miss Marvel's the
modernized version of that so I think
they're doing a really good job
modernizing it even further by having
the medium of TV get you invested in the
family as much or more than the comic
book like I love her family like the
cons are fascinating like when the
Grandma's on screen with the mom I'm not
looking for Kamala I'm like invested in
their relationship and and I think
that's the strength of Television versus
comic books is they have different
things that they do better I don't know
that I'd be as invested in like a
grandma and mom team up comic whereas on
this episode I was like this is dope
yeah how are you feeling about uh the
the villains the clandestines uh they're
not the villains of the comic book
um and that's not a problem but the
clandestines are a very obscure like
miniseries so I'm really curious like
what elements tie into the little I know
about the clandestine that work for Miss
Marvel because it's it's kind of left
field as far as comic fans I mean in
this episode because I remember the last
episode feeling like that Aisha woman
it's kind of scary but then this time I
was like these guys are kind of funny
if they do anything ominous in the next
episode or if we see any history of them
where they do something truly awful that
like makes them scary like it really
felt like main Mentor guy for uh Kareem
was gonna die uh but other than that I
was like I don't know there's not
intimidating anymore yeah well it's
always hard when you have like multiple
action set pieces where you're chasing
someone like you lose intimidation
you're like still gonna get you but at
the end of the day
yeah yeah so like you know even though
people got stabbed it's like gonna get
you the whole episode yeah it's true uh
so you know you're a protagonist you're
gonna be fun yeah yeah she's got to be a
young Avenger well until you had the
compounding tension of like oh my God
there's a big important life event that
this is intervening on in the previous
episode whereas here it's more like cool
new setting personal reason for being
there but it's the street chase and
that's what was hard to have at Hawkeye
too was like you know a lot of times it
was chasing and like I enjoyed that
bridge scene in the car and everything
else in Hawkeye but that was like the
first time I was like okay we're not on
foot with this mob like and it's nice to
mix it up but like when a show has plot
plot plot action plot same action it's
hard to not feel you're like well let's
get back to the yeah but the emotion
might be the thing you were talking
about as well but the emotionality yeah
that thing that I've been Justified
action plot mysticism nor fails the
emotionality of uh just pretty much the
character Expo rate like I just think
it's so cool that this show is actually
not a not shying away from that like the
grandma talking about what is like to
have this like senior ladies
like lamenting of
and the idea that she's still trying to
figure out who she is yeah that's what I
mean like having this identity crisis
over something that wasn't her fault
yeah at all it's just it's kind of the
world she's been born into and then
seeing how even Kamala in the states
also has like issues with this as well
feeling like an outsider amongst her
family inside of her country's you know
her actual family's home food and stuff
enjoyed that identity moment and how it
felt like it mirrored a secret identity
I really enjoyed her talking about her
identity and having dual identities and
like it's a show about a comic book like
these are Kamal economists Marvel or
dual identities and like that spelled
out that way it was really beautiful
because the MCU doesn't have a lot of
secret identities like most everyone
knows who everyone is like capturing
around like I'm Steve Rogers uh so it's
cool to have you know I've been saying
from the jump I think this is going to
lead to kamala's law all I think it's
gonna lead to the Young Avengers now
we're talking about secret identities
but it not being in the superhero sense
but in like how you see yourself and
that's interesting I do think she's
becoming an obnoxiously good fighter a
little too quick hey Rey knew the force
okay very quickly you make a good point
that's the best one in the most best
best Star Wars
there it is Rise of Skywalker
um so yeah all right guys well overall
overall great like show man I'm vibing
with this one I really think it uh the
setting being a character is rad because
that's a huge part of the comic I love
that Jersey City is such an important
character in the book and they've done
Jersey City and Pakistan Justice I think
yeah and I think uh if I'm gonna rank
the guys
I still put Bruno at the top I mean come
on guy in the chair Brian good old Brian
and then uh Cameron and the second oh
over my boy
we just met him stop dude we just met
him and uh I don't know we'll scrape his
hair down though seemed the most generic
of the writing of them so far but he
looked the coolest of the three yeah
great sword work uh knife work for sure
for sure all right guys we are done with
this video
we need more mace in the next episode
we are ready to say goodbye uh do we
have a patron shout outs
we can do more of the the name callouts
we can finish those I say we do it frog
frog You're such not a slog song High
Donald Danny the video game Glover Jacob
Neptune what a way to end June my angel
Gabriel you've never heard that in your
life Mitchell Reed related to Riley Reed
nice
NMB not my boba tea fan popso is running
from the Caps It Don't Mean a Thing If
It Ain't Got Alan Ling don't ever close
the curtains on Logan Burton Kiara come
over here uh you thought I was gonna say
nightly Eric cons 39 we should whine and
dine I love me some coosey coosi Phil
either always getting lost like will
Byers bear in the garage that's recently
been transformed into an Adu Nick you
would never be my ex if we got together
Don Juan Long John Longoria I would
never bail on Gail Ferguson Jaron Werner
Brothers
Studio Pictures always get in the stiff
Mr Cliff Rodriguez Chris Bustin is the
only one I'd be trusting Master T you a
real G call me a homie
bars
John the grandest on any terrain seven
Go goat Akron yeah my oh my is that
Olivia Dell guy
yes
I would love to get drunk within the
funk
Lorenzo Baxter's always getting faster
at commenting on her Legend of Korra and
telling us every thought and opinion
that Lorenzo thinks we have wrong and is
always quick to kind of get into a bit
of an argumentative she disagrees with
someone and we always appreciate the
comments and I'm always a tad nervous as
to what Lorenzo might comment because
Lorenzo had some strong opinions but
when Lorenzo agrees it feels good
because and I feel like I did something
right I feel validated because Mommy and
Daddy never approved to me so when
Lorenzo approves of me I feel like I've
been approved of because it's a
subconscious correlation with my
parental traumas thank you guys so much
for being part of our patreon page and
for pledging to our um this little
specialty here I gotta put a video up
for you all I gotta gets to find some
some deleted footage here but uh thank
you all you guys rock you you rock every
one of you rocks you all are the best
[Music]